مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
نفعة
[موسيقى]
حديثنا اليوم عن لاعب تحول من جيمس بون
بانفيلد من لاعب مرشح للكره الذهبيه من
اللاعب الذي سيغير تاريخ بلاده الى الابد
الى لاعب منسي على رفوف كره القدم وفي
تاريخ كره القدم اللاعب لدفع في ريال
مدريد 60.8 مليون دولار للتعاقد معه
اللاعب اليوما ما وصفه وقال هذا اللاعب
سيكون لاعب المفضل في عالم كره القدم بعد
اداءه المبهر بكاس العالم 2014 وهون
الحديث عن خامس رود خامس اللي بلش مسيرته
مع نادي ايفنغادو اذا قلت اسمه صح
بكولومبيا بموطنه رئيسي وعام 2006 كان
عمره 14 سنه وكان ثاني اصغر لاعب بتاريخ
كولومبيا بيلعب مباراه احترافيه لعب بين
2006 و208 ونجح بانه يخلي او يساعد فريقه
على صعود لدوري الدرجه الممتاز بعام 2008
لفت نظر نادي بانفيلد الارجنتيني قام
تعاقدوا معه مع بانفيلد قدم مستويات كبيره
ولانه قدم مستويات كبيره وبسبب ادائه وق
على قتل الخصوم على طريقه جيمس بوند كرويا
طبعا سموه جمهور بانفيلد جيمس بوند اوف
بانفيت لذلك صار خامس رودريغيز نجم الفريق
وبلش يلفت الانظار باوروبا قدم عرض لضم
اللاعب ولكن العرض رفض وفي عام 2010 قرر
نادي بورتو انه يتعاقد مع خامس وقدم عرض
بقيمه 5 مليون دولار انذاك لضم اللاعب
الكولومبي من بانفيلد وفعلا خامس رودريغيز
حمل حاله راح على البرتغال ليلعب مع نادي
بورتو وكان بنفس الوقت بالمناسبه عم يدرس
بجامعه فنزويليه هندسه كمبيوتر كما يقال
خامس رودريغيز برز بشكل كبير مع بورتو
وقدم مستويات عظيمه جدا لا بل انه اصبح
نجم الفريق الاول بعد رحيل جوارين وفالكاو
وهالك مع نادي بورتو اخذ رقم عشره ومثل ما
حكينا صار النجمه الاول ولكن بورتو غلط
غلطه كبيره وارتكب خطا تاريخي ربما خسروا
15 مليون دولار انذاك برايي الشخصي وهو
انه قرر يبيع اللاعب عام 2013 لنادي
موناكو مقابل 45 مليون يورو كان في ذلك
الوقت مانشستر يونايتد مقدمه عرض ب 30
مليون يورو وهو طبعا ما غلط لانه ما باعوا
لا هو رفض ارض يونايتد وكان معه حق يرفض
ووافق على عرض موناكو لاعب انتقل لموناكو
ب 45 مليون يورو متل ما حكينا وفي عام
2014 اجا كاس العالم وقدم خامس رودريغيز
وحده من اجمل نسخ كاس العالم ووحده من
احلى الاداءات الفرديه للاعب في تاريخ
كؤوس العالمي يمكن واي حدا بيتذكر تلك
النسخه من كاس العالم بقول خامس رودريغيز
كان بطل تلك النسخه مع انه كولومبيا غادرت
مرور النهائي خامس كان هداف تلك البطوله
وافضل لاعب فيها وبالتاكيد بعد تلك
البطوله اختلفت موازين كبيره بالنسبه
لخامس رودريغيز وصار على رادار الانديه
الكبيره جدا باوروبا واحد هذه الانديه كان
ريال مدريد
خامس بكاس العالم طلع بتصريحات لصحيفه
ماركه المقربه من مدريد وقال حلم اللاعب
في ريال مدريد لا يمكن ان ارفض عرض مثل
عرض ريال مدريد بل انه مدعاه فخر بالنسبه
الي انه ريال مدريد يكون مهتم بالتعاقد
معي وبالتالي فعلا راح دق الباب على
موناكو قال لهم تفضلوا هاي ثمانيه مليون
دولار اعطونا خامس قالوا له تفضل خامس على
حسابك انتقل الخامس الى ريال مدريد ويوم
تقديمه حضر حفل تقديمه في الملعب 45 الف
شخص متفرج وكان من ضمنهم سفير كولومبيا في
اسبانيا انذاك اللي وصل رساله من الرئيس
الكولومبي تقول خامس رودريغيز سيغير تاريخ
كولومبيا الى الابد ولكن الاحداث بعد ذلك
اثبتت انه رئيس كولومبيا كان متحمس شوي
زياده وحمل الموضوع اكثر من حقه
بكل صراحه غلطه بورتو كانت انه لو استنوا
على اللاعب بعد سنه واحده كان ممكن يبيعوه
لمدريد هن بستين فاصل ثمانيه مليون وما
يبيعوا موناكو وبالتالي يكسبوا تقريبا 15
مليون زياده حلوين طبعا خامس مع ريال
مدريد جاب لقب دوري ابطال اوروبا 2016 هذا
شيء معروف ولكن بالنسختين هذول الخامس
لاعب 11 مباراه فقط وما كان له تاثير كبير
لانه على ما اذكر انه حط هدف واحد فقط في
نسخه 2016 كان ضد روما اذا ما خاب ظني
وذلك في دور 16 وساهم بتاهل ريال مدريد
انذاك الى ربع النهائي ما عدا ذلك ما كان
في مساهمه كبيره لخامس رودريغيز مع ريال
مدريد لا بل انه زيدان ما كان يعتمد عليه
بشكل اساسي وبالتالي بنهايه موسم 2016
2017 طلب انه يرحل على سبيل الاعاره من
ريال مدريد
وكونه ريال مدريد كان عنده كوكبه من
النجوم ولاعبين كبار انذاك
قالوا له اوكي الله معك روح على بايرن
ميونخ حتى بتذكر انه في عنوان كان لصحيفه
الاساس انذاك عن ايسكو وخامس رود كان
مسميهم قرب رحيل المتعبين الصغار او
مثيرين المشاكل الصغار انتقل خامس
رودريغيز على بايرن ميونخ بعقد اعاره لمده
موسمين الموسم الاول كان طبعا مع كارلو
انشيلوتي اللي هو اصلا كان السبب بانتقاله
على بايرن ميونخ
ادى اداء جيد كان مستواه معقول بالموسم
الثاني كان افضل لدرجه نوكال هاينز
رومانجا شكر انشيلوتي على التعاقد مع خامس
رودريغيز حقق لقب الدوري الالماني مرتين
مع بايرن ميونخ ولكن بنهايه ذلك الموسم
اللي قدم فيه اداء جيد البايرن قالوا له
اسفين نحن ما راح نفعل بند شراء اللاعب
وراح نقول لك الله معك رجاء على ريال
مدريد حمل حاله رجع على ريال مدريد موسم
2019 2020 جاب لقب الدوري مع ريال ولكن
بالنهايه ذلك الموسم انتهت العلاقه مع
الريال وانتهى عقده اصلا مع ريال وانتقل
كلاعب حر لصفوف نادي ايفرتون لا يرجع
يلتقي مجددا مع مدرب وانشيلوتي ولكن هذه
المره في البريميرليج
ليفربول باول موسم مع انشيلوتي قدم خامس
اداءات ممتازه جدا وكان واحد من افضل
لاعبي ايفرتون في تلك النسخه تصدر ببعض
اسابيع الموسم ولكن ما طورت طبعا صدرته بس
بالنهايه قدم موسم جيد جدا بنهايه الموسم
انشروا تفاجا الجميع وعاد الى ريال مدريد
واذا مكانه مين ما كان كثير مقتنع بخامس
رودريغيز وشاف انه هو مش اللاعب الافضل
بالنسبه لايفرتون بسبب اصابته الكثيره
وقال انه نحن ما فينا نعتمد على لاعب
بيقدم 50% من الموسم فقط وباقي الموسم
بيظله مصاب اضف الى ذلك انه خامس رودريغيز
كان اللاعب الاعلى اجرا بتاريخ ايفرتون
وبالتالي بنتائج وقتها لا فينا نستغل هاي
المصاري بامور افضل ونعمل سوق انتقالات
شتوي جيد استغنوا عن خدماته رحل خامس رودز
عن ايفرتون والوجه هالمره كانت قطر راح
على قطر لاعب مع نادي ريال القطري
والتوقعات كبيره انه راح يكون نجم الدوري
القطري راح يقدم مستويات كبيره ولكن ايضا
الاصابات ويقال عدم الانضباط اثروا بشكل
كبير على مستواه وبنهايه الموسم قرر نادي
انه يستغني عن خدمات خامس رودريغيز ويرحل
الى اولمبياكوس طبعا اللاعب تم فسخ عقده
بالتراضي مع الريان وانتقل بعد ذلك الى
اولمبياكوس اليوناني مع اولمبياكوس هو نفس
المسلسل نفس السيناريو المكرر توقعات
كبيره يعني احتفالات كبيره بالفريق انه
اجى خامس رودريغيز الرقم عشره
الرئيس بيمدح فيه المدرب يمدح فيه ولكن
بنهايه الامر خيب كل التوقعات ورحل عن
الفريق بابريل 2023 فسخ عقده اولمبياكوس
يقال انه بسبب كثره الاصابات والان خامس
رودريغيز بلا نادي هو اللاعب اللي تحول من
قمه المجد الى القاع اللاعب اللي كان مرشح
انه يحقق يوما مع الكره الذهبيه الى لاعب
منسي ما حدا عارف عنه شيء وما حدا مهتم
اصلا انه يفكر هو وين او شو صار معه خامس
رودريغيز لاعب جسمه وعقله ما ساعدوه على
تحقيق الانجازات الكبيره وعلى توظيف
مهاراته بالشكل الجديد هذا كان كل شيء
بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع
المقبل